صور اربكت علماء الفضاء والفيزياء ست نقاط
حمراء في عمق الكون لكن وجودها يتناقض مع
النموذج الحالي للكون فالصور التي التقطها
تلسكوب جيمس ويب كشفت عن مجرات هائله تعود
الى عصور مبكره من عمر الوجود عصور لا
يمكن بحسب النظريات السائده ان تنمو فيها
مجرات عملاقه
ومكنت تقنيه استشعار الاشعه تحت الحمراء
تلسكوب الفضاء الشهير من رصد المجرات التي
تشكلت قرابه 500 سنه فقط بعدما يعرف
بالانفجار العظيم اي في مرحله لم يوجد
خلالها ما يكفي من الماده والوقت لتشكيل
مجرات تحتضن مئات الملايين من النجوم
حالها حال مجرتنا درب التبانه التي استغرق
نضوجها اكثر من 13 مليار سنه
[موسيقى]
وفق مجله فان كلا من هذه المجرات تزن
مليارات المرات اكثر من شمسنا وهي حمراء
لان الكون يتمدد والضوء الذي يمر عبره
يتمدد ويصبح اطول موجيه واكثر احمرارا
في السابق مجرتين من المجرات الست الا ان
الصور لم تكن واضحه
[موسيقى]
يستبعد بعض العلماء ان تكون هذه الاجسام
السته مجرات انما هي ماده شديده السخونه
تدور حول ثقب اسود وقد تكون مؤشرا على ان
الامور تسارعت في مراحل نشوء الكون بشكل
اكبر مما كان مت
وقع ان الس
ماء ما كنا نعتقد لصباح العربيه هند
ابراهيم واشنطن